So the first step we're creating it's uh which file ah I need I can stop streaming that's
let me check which file is it
looks like looks like I sent it to you
wow okay let's do this one
is it the test scenarios
yeah it's uh intermined manual test scenarios
yeah uh-huh so what we're doing here it's like a real poster going to the website for personal
he's um
ah price list so we're going to the page uh intermine pricing
and for 30 seconds you need to understand uh what uh happens there is it uh
do you understand what's uh what shot there
let me just get on to pricing
okay uh
yeah this seems pretty standard easy to understand you have very clearly sected
pricing plans
uh the text is very
bold clear very easy to understand
the only thing is maybe the monthly to yearly being a toggle or a switch
is is maybe slightly smaller unclear i don't know
i'm just scrolling down
yeah the the the features how it explains how each plan affects
what you'll have access to quite clear i like the the use of the tick symbols
then you have your faq
that's a free trial work
business include a 14 day free trial
that's hard to start nothing is charged until the trial ends
i like the the little drop down menus are very easy to navigate
um i think the questions that you've chosen are very very uh relevant
is
the answers are good concise
and before you pick a plan yeah i like this as well
uh just
that it allows people to
kind of decide for themselves and see
which part of of the service they'd use the most
just taking a look at use cases
use cases built around multi-lingual collaboration
international exhibitions and conferences
multi-lingual global town halls
yeah i would say
it's very easy to navigate
uh very clear and concise
all the symbols are quite aesthetically pleasing
okay perfect
uh now we are going to the main page uh you need to understand uh what's happened there is it how
how uh how much time it will take you to find the demo button uh without uh registration
uh oh you're already you're already done the faq uh live chat
uh and read some uh landing uh parts
with the case and reviews
and
uh
your comments about it
oh sorry so where do i where am i going now
uh give me a second
yeah now you're going to the intermind.com without slash and into the main page can you just
remove the last part in the browser just leave it to mind.com
yeah and the same thing describe what you're seeing just growing the page
very clear slogan straight away stop running meetings in your in someone else's language
intermind translates voice chat and share docs live so each person speaks and reads their own
on a sovereign eu engine that you can audit
uh yeah i have a very simple clear description of what the service provides what it does
then i mean the the live demo the very clear button there's the contrast between the light
blue and the dark background to make it easier to find and there's the benchmarks as well
where your daughter lives translation translation photo uh okay i see there's a blog here uh that's
interesting i'm not is there is there certain parts you want me to go through first or just
kind of how i would go through the the website all right uh okay i'll track try with my parts what
what i'm seeing um on the main page intramind.com uh i'm seeing that uh slogan is very clear uh i see the
first uh uh first links to the sovereignty research methodology release methodology architecture now there's
uh i see that uh some of the text is almost uh uh same color as a background so it's a bit hard to read
and some of the text is extremely small yeah i don't see i see that on the sovereignty page uh some of the
the numbers are a bit uh not in the center of the circle
what i see here why intertwined i scrolled a bit lower uh it shows very clearly and let's check
how it works translate voice charts this page it works
uh real time translation end to end uh everything here looks very clearly uh page opens uh successfully
see here i'm scrolling down and everything is perfect
yeah everything is pretty clear next one collaborative meeting workspace
page opened everything looks clear
no bugs okay to the next one
privacy and security page opened
yeah everything looks clear in this part
so with um
i'm scrolling down the main page
and i see that everything is fine here
okay what's next demo let's try a demo
yeah you can uh yeah just uh check the demo by yourself
for a few minutes what you see what's how it works
uh let's try and into my demo
page opens successfully
all the standard formatting is correct
there's the
okay okay i'm just gonna click on start demo
i do notice that um
on the description where it says you'll be asked to allow camera and microphone access
i think there's a space between the the spacing between the letters on some of the demo mode is a bit
strange but that that's just a bit nitpicking nitpicking
um
so i'll just click on start demo is that good
yep okay requesting permissions
the pop-up shows up use your microphones use your cameras
i'll allow
setting up the demo
speak on the left here translation on the right
okay everything seems to be working well it's just loading
okay there you go you can see me my camera's working multiple languages detected participants speak different languages
i see myself on both sides of the screen
let me just see
taalherkenning
deelnemers spreken verschillende talen
ik zie mezelf aan beide kanten van het scherm
ik kan het in mijn stem horen
dat is heel vreemd
dat is eigenlijk best wel cool
ik kan het in mijn stem horen
dat is heel vreemd
dat is eigenlijk best wel cool
ik kan het in mijn stem horen
dat is heel vreemd
dat is eigenlijk best wel cool
ik kan het in mijn stem horen
dat is heel vreemd
dat is eigenlijk best wel cool
ik kan het in mijn stem horen
dat is heel vreemd
dat is eigenlijk best wel cool
laat me even enkele van de instellingen bekijken
zodat je de camera kunt uitschakelen
oké, dus de mute werkt
deelnemers tonen
hoe sluit ik dit
dus dat was vrij eenvoudig
te navigeren
dit is dus een volledige transcriptie
van alles wat ik in het Engels zeg
en dus stel ik me voor dat
als ik dat aan de andere kant ook probeer
laten we het afronden
ik ben niet zeker of er een transcriptie
van wat ik hier in Nederland zeg
zou moeten zijn
maar er staat niets
misschien niet
misschien is dat hier gewoon
de chat
als transcriptie
oké
laten we het scherm delen proberen
dit kan een beetje een inleiding zijn
alleen het hele scherm
oké, deel ook het systeemgeluid
oké, oké
ik denk dat dat...
wat is creating a infinite loop?
sorry, sorry...
ah, met video?
oké, sorry...
sorry, sorry...
je mentioned dat dat is creating an infinite loop
sorry...
ah, met video?
oké, oké, oké, oké, oké, oké, oké
oké, oké, oké, oké, oké, oké, oké, oké, oké
oké, oké, oké, oké, oké, oké, oké, oké
let's try some emotes...
try to reopen demo...
but change in language...
dat is geen probleem...
eh...
let me open demo by myself...
dus hoe verander ik de...
there should be a button in languages...
eh...
I can disable translation...
English and Russian...
so...
if I disable translation...
yeah, then I can just hear myself in English...
open settings...
dot translation language...
so...
maybe I do...
is there any language...
you want me to...
try to change it to Russian...
maybe I'll hear it...
Russian?
yeah...
oké...
and then...
let me turn...
enable translation...
hello...
testing...
I cannot speak Russian...
oh...
I think maybe I'm muted...
no...
let's...
we'll check language translation...
in the meeting room...
when we'll be together...
I think that's better...
now...
it's a bit tough...
I understand...
oh...
hello...
testing...
I don't speak Russian...
oh...
I think...
I'll stop...
oké...
let's try again...
it's not happening now...
now...
we'll see...
let's see...
yeah...
leave demo...
and try to reopen it...
for a few minutes...
or...
for a minute...
and check that...
everything opens fine...
ok...
ends demo...
and then...
go back in...
or...?
yeah...
start demo again...
ok...
and what's the process...
what's the difference in the process?
uh...
everything looks pretty much...
exactly the same...
it's loading up again...
this is...
transcribing in German now...
so it's changed the...
the language...
this is...
uh...
everything seems...
pretty much...
now...
it's pretty much...
so...
has the language changed?
yeah...
I mean...
everything seems...
quite exactly the same...
other than the language...
I don't know if that's...
like a...
wise thing...
just for the demo...
which...
I don't think...
that something really changed...
except for the language...
I don't know...
I don't know if that is...
it's like a...
just for the demo...
I think...
yeah...
is there anything else...
you want me to try...
in the demo...
just like...
it's the last part...
in...
in this section...
in a...
part one...
now...
try to open...
demo room...
from a phone...
if it possible...
yeah...
I can do that...
okay...
uh...
should I join...
Discord on my phone...
and a screenshot...
or...
like...
because I can't...
record...
yeah...
now I need to record...
just uh...
yeah...
just say what you...
what you see...
what's wrong...
or what's correct...
or...
like...
because I can't...
take off my phone...
no need to record...
just turn off the...
the...
translation...
or...
let me...
myself...
so I'm not having a...
I'm gonna sit...
the back of my skull...
just logging in...
that's just a standard...
log in with Google...
everything seems to be working...
ok...
I logged in successfully...
I see...
the...
meetings page...
I think...
I'm not on the actual...
forum...
forum page...
of the...
the...
meetings page...
I think...
I'm not on the actual...
forum...
forum page...
of the...
the website...
where I can try...
the demo...
on...
like...
the account...
page...
let me try this again...
ok...
I'm just going...
to redo that...
to my own...
dot com...
ok...
I'm seeing the...
exact same things...
that I saw...
on...
the...
web version...
everything seems...
properly formatted...
for...
uh...
for the iPhone...
I can see...
we still have...
some of those same...
formatting issues...
on the...
like...
sovereignty...
and...
uh...
the...
blog posts...
where the text...
is a bit small...
and some of the numbers...
are off-centred...
in those...
dot points...
um...
do you just want me to try...
a live demo...
or...
go through how...
the whole...
side...
yeah...
try everything...
that you've not tried...
but...
it's...
uh...
let's finish this part...
I think...
uh...
let's stop recording...
cause...
uh...
it's...
we're finished with a part 1...
part 0...
and part 1...
so...
we...
you'll save this recording...
ok...
stop...